Being a mother is a very big role
and there is no manual that tells you look,
this is the way to be a mother, that is what
I am still learning, it is like being a
mother, being a wife, giving myself time
every day I give thanks I
live  a lot, that's why I write three things
for which I am thankful I think I was
very much in love with myself and my husband but
later we agreed that we love our
son more than we love
ourselves and it is and it is a love that surpasses everything
we behave fabulous we are  wonderful and
what a great job they do and that sometimes we
have to go through circuits and that are a
little more difficult as mothers
whether you are a working
mother or a single mother but always the most
important thing is to put your children first
for me to be a mother  It has been something very
particular because when I was 21
years old they told me I couldn't have children
so for me being a mother
has not only been a blessing for everyone,
but for me it has
literally been a blessing.  tion because
doctors had told me that I was not going to be
able to have children so I always
always tell them don't give
up if they tell you that you can't because you
never know how to be a mother for me I have been very
the most beautiful thing that has happened to me
is a  The moment we know we are
pregnant was one of the most special moments.
I love my son, he is my life and
at 9 banic time frame reported for us
Nao in Spanish
Natalia Lanzelotti
[Music]